es el primer asesinato político en esta
precampaña de cara a las elecciones
presidenciales del próximo mes de
octubre marcelo ruda era líder del
partido de los trabajadores el pp en
iguazú una ciudad turística del sur del
país en el estado del paraná estaba
celebrando sus 50 años en una fiesta
temática donde había muchas fotos del ex
presidente luis inácio lula da silva
irrumpió un policía supuestamente
simpatizante de bolsonaro según fuentes
de este partido y abrió fuego contra
este líder del partido de los
trabajadores que a su vez se defendió
con su arma de fuego porque también era
policía municipal
resultado tanto el agresor como el
agredido han fallecido sin embargo no ha
sido el primer ataque recordamos que el
7 de julio aquí en el centro de río de
janeiro hubo un comicio de lula y en
este comicio nombre lanza un artefacto
con heces humanas en el medio la
muchedumbre que explotó y acabó hiriendo
el brazo de una mujer tanta es la
preocupación por la seguridad que en ese
mismo comisión llevaba debajo de su
camisa un chaleco antibalas y además a
mediados de junio hubo otro ataque desde
un drones de nuevo con heces humanas
contra la muchedumbre en otro comienzo
de lula todo es apunta a que la campaña
o mejor dicho precampaña está cada vez
más polarizada y que esta polarización
puede aumentar a lo largo de los
próximos meses